the the thing that has hit me joel is
that i used to think that
if you had enough people on board with
something then that would get the job
done
but now i'm realizing that our
government is increasingly detached from
what it is that we all want uh and i've
been
digging into some of the structural
reasons why that is so part of it is
this 21
um satisfaction rate 94 re-election rate
you're like well
that's a pretty big divide like if if i
was uh
let's say running a company i'd be like
this might not be introducing the
feedback
that i'm looking for uh but it
because our government like you said
people just have just
thought okay this is the way it is so it
so it was so it ever shall be
uh and so now now for me it really is
about the systems it's like
okay how do our elected representatives
get elected how do they keep getting
reelected
what are their incentives how does the
leadership work
this is the this is a gridlock that's
happened over and over on a thousand
different things
uh and i mean obviously going back a few
administrations
and where they just were like we're just
not going to do any we're just not going
to help you at all
how what's the salute how would you
change that system
so that would stop all right here are
a few big things that we need to do
number one
is public campaign financing so that if
you run and you get a certain number of
signatures you get some public money
enough to be competitive uh my proposal
during the campaign was 100 democracy
dollars for every voter you can give to
any candidate you want and so then if
i got 10 000 people behind me i get a
million bucks and that's enough for me
to
to compete and run wash out some of the
corporate money
uh because right now just the companies
are
bombing hundreds of millions of dollars
into various campaigns so that's that's
big
domino number one number two is
uh open primaries in place of these
party primaries
and trying to make the districts more
competitive
so right now over 80 percent of the
congressional districts are
either clean republican or clean
democrat in other words
there's no there's no uncertainty as to
who's going to win the general election
and so if you're a member of congress in
one of these
safe seats then you don't care about
compromising with the other side you
just care about not getting primaried by
someone in your own party
typically someone much more extreme and
so that ends up distorting your
legislative
incentives because it's like well i'd
rather just seem like
i'm like very very strong on this side
and if nothing gets done
like i'm safe but if i were to reach
across the aisle and compromise and do
something that some people are unhappy
with
that's actually very bad for me in terms
of my reelection prospects
that's the current set of incentives
that they have so if you had open
primaries instead of the closed primary
system
then you'd have to reach out to more
people in your district and not just
satisfy
the the folks in your party the big
change in this direction that would be
huge is rank choice voting because then
if you have a number of
people in the district and it's open
and ranked choice voting then
makes it so that no one's worried about
wasting their vote for number one
because right now
it's like oh you can't vote for that
person you're going to end up costing us
this election
if you have ranked choice voting you can
vote for whoever the heck you want and
then trust that
your your vote's going to end up counted
in the best way possible
uh and it also diminishes the incentives
to
campaign negatively because if you're if
let's say there are five of you in the
field and i trash
candidate number two then that person
looks bad i look bad and then candidate
number three is going to come up in
petersburg
so at right choice voting elections
everyone plays it
more above board because when you start
throwing rocks at people like
you know you look bad and the person
you're throwing rocks at looks bad
so so these would be the the biggest
changes you could make
but the the change that i think has been
rattling around for a long time that i
am totally for that would change this
um maybe the most dramatically is just
term limits for members of congress
where if you have a term it's a little
bit like
term uh 18-year terms for supreme court
justices
but we're making almost the equivalent
of lifetime appointments in congress
right now where you have dozens of
members of congress who've been there
for
30 or 40 years uh you know like
and you can see it too in the age of our
leadership
where not to knock you know because
there are a lot of
like awesome um people of any generation
any stage but we have the
equivalent of a gerundocracy right now
which is the reason why things feel the
way that they do
i mean the average age of a u.s senator
i believe is 62.
if you look at leadership nancy pelosi
steny hoyer mitch mcconnell
are all in their 70s or even 80s i
believe in one case
so you we we have a system that is
rewarding
seniority to the nth degree in congress
and nothing ever changes so i would have
term limits for members of congress and
what's wild joel is when i looked into
this it turns out the vast majority of
americans intuitively agree with
with term limits like it has something
like a 78 or 80
approval rating so think about that for
a second like what can you get 80
of americans to agree on like not a
whole lot but you can get them to agree
on the fact that
good that's something they would all
agree on i like chocolate and then yeah
about 80 yeah it's like i like chocolate
and
if i send someone to dc they should
eventually come back
[Laughter]
about the only two things they can agree
on how do you get them to vote on
something that would limit them
that's literally so counterintuitive
well my my big proposal joel is
term limits for members of congress but
current
current members are exempt or
grandfathered in so
if you're a current legislator you might
get on board with this because you're
like well
like doesn't affect me
and it turns out strong thurman was
actually still alive and he's like it's
fine with me i'm 125
now and yeah how long did he let he was
like there when he was 94
something like that yeah he he got up
there
uh so those are some of the big
structural fixes uh if there's something
that i'm excited about
right now that's sweeping the nation it
is ranked towards voting because some
states are voting on it right now
i think massachusetts is going to pass
it maine already has it
i think seattle and new york city have
it too not statewide but
but in the cities so when voters find
out about rank choice voting
they love it they get excited because
everyone realizes it's just a better
expression of
preference and it's a better democracy
it's just a higher functioning democracy
if you can just say look i like this
person first this person's second
this person third and then after that i
refuse to even express a preference
because i hate everyone else like that's
fine you know like that that would that
would work
that would have worked wonders um over
the last
number of uh presidential cycles too to
be honest with you because
if you look at what was going on in the
republican primary in
uh trump was trump won those
primaries but he wasn't getting 50 in a
lot of the places
you know that there were a lot of places
early on whereas like trump with hit
with his crowd
but then there were you know whatever
six or seven other candidates and they
were splitting up the rest
if you had ranked choice voting it might
be that someone else would have emerged
on top
yeah no i and it's one of those things
when you say it you're like yeah why
isn't
it it seems so it's such a seems so
logical isn't like yeah well that's
that seems like such a well that's what
you do if you
you if you're in a boat you need an ore
because that makes you
move like right that seems perfectly
reasonable
and it doesn't seem that complicated at
all
well yeah it's not when people find out
about rank choice voting
um it ends up winning everything because
everyone looks at him he's like well
that just seems better that's more
logical like we should just do that
uh and right now the the only resistance
is from frankly uh folks who are
currently
in power who like the 94 reelection rate
who are like oh no
like this is going to complicate my life
like i've got my
dollar moat all set up i could just like
i could just
crouch here forever in the current
system so
uh but the average voter loves it and if
we can get that done for anyone who
wants a more vibrant democracy or is
thinking that there's a need for a third
party
in the united states of america or other
major parties because the
current two-party system might not be uh
humming uh then you should just get
behind ranked choice voting because
the great thing about it is it's
non-partisan bipartisan it's like looks
just better process better democracy
but it ends up enabling uh
more dynamic uh third party candidates
as well because then the third party
candidate can show up and be like
don't worry you're not going to help
that person you hate get elected or like
you're not going to be wasting your vote
and you can still vote for me
and like people because right now that
that argument
actually is very very powerful on people
it's like no one wants to help
um you know the person they like the
least get elected
massachusetts seattle new york have it
massachusetts is voting on it right now
um maine has it
uh and then new york and seattle i
believe just recently adopted it or are
voting on it right
yeah and they gotta get rid of you know
the the college
you know the uh what do you call it the
uh electoral college yeah that is
i i just and i i know this is why i feel
right about this
is because even when i was six years old
and they were explaining government to
me and i was just like
what i'm so confused why is it called a
college
a b uh what is the point of it
and i couldn't i still to this day are
like so
we and and it doesn't make any sense
at all and i get that it has benefited
both parties
it has benefited the republican party
most recently
uh with like bush gore and obviously
trump uh
clinton but it's benefited the democrats
at some point
but i still to this day it's just like
the popular vote seems
as simple occam's razor that
is the straightest thing lying to
electing the most popular person so
here's my proposal for the electoral
college reform that i think would make
everyone happy
so the one problem with trying to
abolish it is that you need a
constitutional
uh amendment super majority to do it and
you'd have
a dozen states that are like wait a
minute i'm less influential under
you know the popular vote system because
i'm nebraska i'm montana like you know
like the electoral college helps me
so so then you so you run into a very
very practical problem where it's like
i'll never get this changed because
there are a lot of people i'll be
shooting themselves in the foot
um there's a there's a legitimate reason
to which which is that
let's say we had popular vote and i was
running for president which i did thank
you everyone who supported me
really appreciate it uh then i i would
never leave a major media market i would
always be in a major media market
because i'll just get more votes
yeah and then if i went if i went to
some less populated area it'd just be a
waste of time
um now right now like the balance might
be excessive in a particular direction
but
you know i don't i'm not sure it'd be
optimal for us just to be
campaigning on the coaster in the big
cities so the the change that would
that's practical and doable that most
everyone should get behind that would
also help
ease this problem is you make it so that
the electoral college
awards its votes not winner take all by
state
but proportionally by state so in other
words uh if
you know if california has 40 electoral
votes or more
then they get awarded proportional to
how many
how much i won that state by so instead
of getting all of them i'd get
60 of them or something along those
lines and if you did that then all of a
sudden the incentives for
national candidates would be to campaign
anywhere they can actually move the
margin
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]